is the youtube algorithm against small
channels is it still possible to grow on
youtube with all of these large channels
that seem to be getting all of the views
and ultimately going into 2022
is it too late to start youtube you know
one of the things i hear a lot is man
youtube's just too crowded is youtube
worth my time have you ever asked
yourself that is there any opportunity
left on
youtube and in this video we're actually
going to be talking about not my opinion
not hype from somebody that's just
throwing out youtube platitudes that
they heard on a different channel but
we're actually going to be talking about
six specific insights from a youtube
employee in fact the product manager at
youtube shared these at a conference
recently that are going to kind of
surprise you and peel back the curtain
about what's really happening with the
youtube
algorithm and so buckle your seat belt
because today in coffee with cannell
we're going to be going deep into how to
grow your channel how to start a channel
from scratch and how to understand the
algorithm so you can beat it and get
more views welcome to coffee with
cannell three two one
[Music]
welcome back to coffee with kennel sean
kennel here if we're just meeting uh my
passion is to help you build your
influence on youtube i'm the co-author
of the number one best-selling youtube
strategy book in the world youtube
secrets and i'm excited to get into
today's
episode recently at a conference vid
summit shout out to derral eves todd
bupre the product manager at youtube
shared a very powerful session and
revealed six insights that you're going
to want to know that really answer the
question is there still opportunity to
grow on youtube right now here's number
one
over 600 million
different videos are recommended every
day
on the youtube home page
by the way if you're studying your
analytics that's your browse features
and
up next which is suggested videos when
you're studying your youtube traffic
okay so why does this answer the
question
is the youtube algorithm against small
channels is it too late to start youtube
this is coming straight from data from
youtube and they're saying this
over the next 24 hours
600 million different videos are showing
up on people's home pages
now
you can imagine large channels have a
couple videos that are being spread like
mr beast might be showing up on a lot of
home pages you know with a lot of
different videos he's made maybe and
maybe your favorite in fact tell me in
the comments who's your favorite
youtuber or big youtube channel or
whatever size
but the crazy thing here is even if we
cut that number in half
that could be representative of 300
million different creators unique
creators that are getting a chance a
shot to show up on the youtube homepage
or to be recommended off of after
somebody else's video this stat alone i
hope was worth your time for coming to
coffee with candle today smash like if
you're pumped about the opportunity on
youtube
and and so i want to encourage you
don't see the limitations see the
possibilities what todd was trying to
say was that there is so much
opportunity on youtube and the algorithm
is trying to find videos to satisfy
viewers and every and a new day new
opportunities like every new day is a
new opportunity for you to get one video
out
recommended
and remember you're always one video
away from changing your life your
business your youtube channel now if
you're new to the youtube algorithm
remember that each youtube viewer is
getting unique personalized
recommendations
like the youtube homepage isn't just
some
billboard of the most popular youtube
videos and as we go throughout this
training you're going to be seeing uh
that there's actually a lot of
opportunity the more you niche down and
really understand what kind of content
you're creating for you to get
discovered so that's just a fact this is
this is facts from the inside of youtube
from a youtube employee that 600 million
different videos are recommended every
day um
again if you're just joining
uh the topic today is is the youtube
algorithm against small channels six
surprising insights from a youtube
employee here's number two the 7x rule
if a hundred viewers watched last week
700 potential viewers see your
thumbnails this week
let me know how many views are you
getting on your channel per week the way
you can see that is you go into your
youtube analytics and it'll tell you in
the last 28 days or rather in the last
month how how many views did you get in
the last month
you know you could cut that you can
actually go and select last seven days
so you could see
uh
how many views did you get in the last
week
and here's what todd was revealing now i
added the 7x rule he didn't call it a
rule and it might change over time but
this is what it is this is brand new hot
off the presses fresh info for you
if you got a hundred views in the last
seven days
the next seven days the youtube
algorithm
is going to show
your videos to 700 people
seven times whatever your views were
last week
how do they show your videos
on the home page in suggested videos and
up next they're gonna be showing the
title and the thumbnail it's if you read
this it's potential viewers you go well
i got 100 views i didn't get 700 and i'm
not saying you're going to get 700 views
the next week
i'm saying
you're going to have the potential
if youtube says man if people are
consuming your content this week we want
to see and test your content with new
wider audiences and so the 7x rule is a
massive opportunity telling us that it's
not too late to start going into 2022
that there's if you're starting from
scratch
sure how do you get those first views
well subscribe to this channel because
we have all kinds of content to help you
start from zero but as soon as you're
getting views
you have a chance to be showing up and
being recommended next week showing up
on the home page this is real data and
here's how they illustrated it here's a
screenshot of his presentation at
vidsummit
it shows you that this group of people
on the left here 100 viewers last week
700 potential viewers will see your
thumbnail the following week
i also just want to encourage you if
you're feeling discouraged on youtube
don't quit if you're getting some
momentum now keep going and remember
that small tweaks lead to giant peaks
remember that get one percent better
with every video because as you improve
your content youtube builds momentum
it's like a snowball the snowball gets
bigger as more momentum increases and as
you keep putting out quality content and
improving your content
well hey if you're new to the coffee
with kennel show today's episode we've
got you know six more tips for you i got
a bonus tip uh but today's episode is
brought to you by the think media
podcast
and if you have not subscribed to the
think media podcast yet um definitely do
so it's your weekly deep dive into the
best youtube growth tips for getting
views and making money listen to new
episodes every tuesday on youtube
spotify apple or whatever you listen
wherever you listen to podcasts
if you're tired of outdated youtube
advice that just isn't working and you
want real strategic insights
for starting and growing a youtube
channel right now
just search think media podcast and make
sure to subscribe so you do not miss an
episode and by the way if you are a
think media podcast listener shout me
out in the comments
and if you haven't left a review on
apple podcast that would mean the world
to me if you've been getting value from
it
we we post a lot of deep dive content
there and so uh you'll enjoy that number
three
here is the formula
for how the algorithm works directly
from a youtube employee
here we go personalization
plus performance
plus external factors
equal
home page ranking
if you want to get recommended by
youtube you want to show up on you want
to have your video show up on the home
page you want
your content to reach more people
these are the factors well sean what
does that mean i'm glad you asked
so here's
the slide where he showed this he said
personalization including your watch
history
performance including appeal engagement
and viewer satisfaction and external
factors like topic interest competition
and seasonality let's break them down
so
this is a crazy uh quote from todd
history is the most influential factor
in what we recommend
that's worth taking a breath and really
thinking about that
the most influential and i quote factor
of what videos are being recommended on
youtube
is a viewer's
watch
history well sean what does that mean
for me i mean i'm trying to i got a new
i'm creating new content i'm trying to
make my own stuff and build my own brand
what it means is this we say it all the
time
the creator who understands the viewer
best wins
you should be creating content not in
some unique niche that nobody else is
doing because the watch history in some
obscure thing or just if your channel
has no niche and it's just your random
thoughts
then how does youtube even know to
recommend you
but
if you're creating tiny home content or
like home decor content or diy content
people are watching tiny home content or
home decor content or other types of
content like that on youtube right
and so their watch history is telling
youtube the kind of content they're
interested in
so if you want to grow right now and
start a channel
what you want to do is you actually want
to be creating content in a proven
niche
you want to be creating content in
something that there actually is already
verified interest in
so look at the most influential factor
and this is what youtube is looking at
first they're looking at what other
channels does the viewer watch what
other channels is the viewer subscribe
to
what other topics does the viewer watch
and what videos does the viewer watch
and once youtube starts to identify that
it'll start recommending videos even if
they're not
even if they don't have a youtube
channel it'll do this
you log into a fresh account or you log
into a fresh smart tv and you don't even
log into youtube
youtube sees where you go once you
search for what you click on and the
youtube algorithm immediately gets to
work to recommend similar content
they're like if they liked this they'll
probably like this
so here's my question to you what is if
they liked what what channels if they
liked what content and how does your
content relate
to that other content
are you making content related to
content that is proven on
youtube
so then it layers on top of that
data about the user the context meaning
time of day performance data and then
essentially everybody's getting a
personalized ranking so kind of gone are
the days of thinking i'm just trying to
be the king of youtube and i'm trying to
just rank at the top of the mountain
what you need to understand is there's
multiple little mountains
you're actually your goal is to be at
the top of a smaller mountain
you could be youtube famous in a niche
and nobody even knows you
it happens all the time i mean so many
of our students that we have all these
students in our video ranking academy
program full-time uh making you know 4k
a month 5k a month 10k a month uh you
know they go someplace and people come
up to them at the grocery store but you
would have no clue who they are it's
like they're in a might they have micro
fame they're micro known
on a smaller mountain your goal is not
to rank at the top of youtube your goal
is to rank at
the mini niche
and if you can be at the top of a
smaller niche there there you're getting
the traffic the suggested videos the
search rankings
and so
that's why rankings look at that last
thing there i'm circling it personalized
right they're personalized
okay
so what are these three factors this is
going to help you understand the youtube
algorithm and here's the simple fact
friend the youtube algorithm is not
against small channels
small channels just need to
improve their content
pivot their strategy
and keep persevering
using the data in this video from a
youtube employee
and you will have your breakout video if
you apply this information
so personalization
think about this this is the first
factor in what youtube is recommending
it's asking what other videos is the
viewer watching it's asking what other
channels do they watch listen to this
it's asking what videos do they skip
so a viewer scrolling over videos
it's a form of engagement for you to be
on your phone and to pass over a video
youtube knows more about you not just
from what you actually watch but what
you don't watch
because it goes okay cool the more they
skip over this the more we're gonna
refine what we're recommending to them
well sean how do i apply this to my
channel
have you researched
the top 5 to 15 channels
it's your channel cluster that you would
love to be recommended with
don't view them as competitors view them
as collaborators because if there's
already a group of channels getting
views in a particular niche and you want
to be a part of that niche
then you want to be recommended what
other videos are they watching what
other channels are they watching and how
can you create related content to that
what are they not interested in
you understand the viewer you're trying
to reach to a greater degree when you
not only know what they like but you
know what they don't like
and how long do they watch of course
view duration
and then also when do they watch even to
the time of day todd was talking about
how you'll get different recommendations
on your phone than you do on your smart
tv at night
and ultimately the youtube algorithm is
watching 80 billion signals over 80
billion right data points so it's not
about knowing all of those little points
but it is about understanding number one
personalization this is almost
this is completely in your control
because it's going to inform your whole
strategy but remember todd's quote
history is the most influential factor
in what we recommend so it's really
smart for you to make sure you pick the
right niche pick the right positioning
and you're making the right video topics
secondly is performance
layered on top of that now if you want
your videos to rank and show up and you
want to beat the algorithm
then things like click through rate the
watch time of your video likes and
dislikes shares not interested feedback
people can
click on that little window and say i'm
not interested in a video like this and
youtube really pays attention to that
pre and post watch surveys
and more so there's all these
performance data points these are some
of the biggest ones
and if you can improve these
both likes and dislikes that's
engagement more watch time minutes
higher click through rate are people
clicking share is your video shareable
are people selecting not interested
you can't necessarily control that but
that's
how polarizing you are or how clear your
niche is or how clear your values or
your stance is even in the content idea
it just youtube then knows who to serve
that video to and maybe who not to pre
and post surveys we also don't get to
see these surveys but here is a big
light bulb moment we'll cover it a
little bit later as well
there's something that's more important
to watch time
at youtube and we say all the time
minutes matter most what it actually is
is viewer satisfaction and what todd
said was not all watch time is
considered equal
so what he's saying is actually these
pre-surveys and these post surveys is
like okay you just spent 15 minutes
watching a video
are you satisfied and they give you a
little survey
i've seen them on mobile smartphone and
desktop they don't you don't they don't
always show up but youtube has 2.3
billion monthly active users so they're
testing these surveys
so not all watch time is created equal
what is the summary of kind of the whole
mission
viewer satisfaction
yes minutes matter most in a high
click-through rate but if somebody
here's what youtube explained and todd
explained
see if somebody spent 20 minutes
watching youtube but left at the end of
that session with like a sick feeling in
their stomach like imagine like you you
spent an hour on the speed date with the
person on that first date with the
person and like at the end of it it was
a horrible hour it's like so you got the
time but the the net result was like you
ever done that you like you're like ugh
that's sucked i wish i could get that
time back
so youtube's mission is not only to have
people spend minutes on the platform
they want people to keep returning and
having a good experience
so if they have somebody they're like oh
we got an hour of watch time from them
today but that person was like i'm never
watching youtube again i've got a sick
filling in my stomach
then youtube ultimately would lose their
long-term goal of having repeat viewers
coming back to spend lots of time on the
platform
so the algorithm's mission
is not just watch time but it's viewer
satisfaction and that's where the
surveys come in they're not interested
feedback and so
these data points
layered on top of viewers expressing
what kind of content they're interested
in will determine if your video ranks
and then there's the final one is
external factors
which include things like potential
audience size
audience interest over time supply and
demand and seasonality and i'll show you
we'll go a little bit deeper on these
so sometimes if you're frustrated or
you're frustrated with how fast your
channel is growing it could be because
you don't even have a large enough
potential audience size for your
ambition when it comes to youtube
it could be that you just started doing
gameplay
of videos on a game that's losing
popular popularity audience interest is
changing
it also could be that there's so much
competition in one area you need to
pivot a little bit because supply
is supply and demand there's demand but
supply is over inflated in an area you
need to pivot to where supply and demand
is lower and then it also could just be
the time of year so let's go deeper into
these
this is just an example he showed
saying
some
potential audience that some topics have
larger potential audiences than others
for example soccer football has 3.5
billion people that are interested in it
cricket the game has 2.5 billion and
golf has 450 million
now all of those are great niches
but it kind of gives you an idea that
the question you should ask is
what is the potential audience size for
my channel how big could my channel be
see savvy business owners and
entrepreneurs
do market research before they enter
into a market and they look for what's
called the tam
tam the total addressable market another
way for putting that is what is the
potential audience size
you know you might sell if you're a
business owner some widget that a very
small percentage of the population is
into now if you're the only person
selling it then maybe supply and demand
there's not very much demand but you're
the only supplier and it's created a
great business for you or a great
youtube channel for you
but the total addressable market the
potential audience size really really
matters now hit like if you're getting
value are we talking is this a little
deep do you like when i go into some of
this nuance i know this isn't like
basic level algorithmic youtube strategy
this is a pretty high level but let me
know if you like videos like this and if
you want to see more trainings like this
so
we're talking about external factors
that influence your videos ranking and
showing up on the homepage so one is the
potential audience size
one is keep in mind audience interest
will change over time and i love this
example and what todd is doing using
here is he's using google trends
if you haven't used google trends before
it's a great way to compare different
markets and popularity
so if you can see on screen here and i
realize these slides don't look the best
but
what he did is he's comparing fortnite
minecraft roblox and among us
so it doesn't matter if you're in gaming
or not you could do this excuse me in
health and you might compare vegan paleo
keto and you're looking at different
terms maybe in your industry in your
niche and seeing how they've risen and
fall fallen and this is a five-year
window and notice some of the selections
he's made this is in the past five years
worldwide and it's youtube search that
he's studying so you see that fortnight
only started to rise once it was created
it had to actually start you see among
us as in the green is over underneath
his arm it had a steep spike and then it
really has become the least viewed
game in terms of trends and interest
you see roblox has been steady and it is
even climbing right now you see
minecraft has been has had ups and downs
but has been the most influential over
time and you also see fortnight's going
down a little bit here's the point
you're wondering why are my views up or
down
um and audience interest really matters
and if if your market meaning if the
interest of the audience is declining
then it would be shocking for your
channel to be growing
so if you really want to have a banger
or youtube channel
if you had
low competition but high audience and
market growth you know audience interest
is going up
there's not a ton of people doing it
um you're putting out quality content
you're getting good performance but
there is interest in personalization
things are happening that would be if
you were just sitting
thinking about starting a new channel
pivoting your channel um or just
thinking about what types of topics of
videos to make even if you make one-off
video that ties into something like how
could you tie in squid game right now to
like your con three business lessons
from squid game or something like that
just because you're you're jumping on
audience interest this matters as well
next is supply and demand
so i'll read from his slide and it says
this even if your video is performing
well compared with other videos on a
channel it may receive fewer impressions
if videos from other channels are
performing even better
so we have to acknowledge
that
you go sean i made a video about
something popular
but it's just not really breaking
through well if
a hundred of the top biggest channels
also made the exact same video as you
then supply and demand wise it's going
to be hard to break through that's why
we spend so much time inside of video
ranking academy encouraging you to find
nuanced angles
and nuanced video topics even if there's
smaller interest maybe there's lower
demand
but there's also like no supply
and this is how you start from scratch
that's how you grow from zero because
eventually you will be a medium-sized
channel or a big channel and you will it
won't be david versus goliath anymore
you might be goliath now and you can
make different decisions
but
supply and demand matters in terms of
you're like i'm doing everything right
well maybe it's a topic that is super
saturated however there's some good news
on this slide and it says keep in mind
many viewers watch a hundred plus
channels per month
so i need to call out some of us here in
the think media community because
honestly you're spending a lot of time
overthinking
and a lot of time there's so many videos
you should make and you're just you're
actually over thinking oh there probably
is too much competition i probably just
shouldn't even make that video
man i don't know i watched that training
from sean and i was gonna make that but
i don't know i what do i have to add
stop it make the video like keep in mind
many viewers are watching 100 channels
per month keep in mind that if someone's
going to buy a new backpack or they're
going to invest in some health equipment
or something they're probably going to
watch three or four or five or six
different perspectives on that and you
have the chance to be a part of that if
someone in your niche is getting a
million views a video you have a chance
to get 10 000 views but not if you don't
make the dang video
and so
be aware of supply and demand but this
information shouldn't paralyze you it
actually should lead you to just taking
smart strategic action stop overthinking
stop making excuses stop studying your
competition for weeks on end and pick up
a sling david and five smooth stones and
just go after goliath because
overthinking is going to kill your
channel
seasonality
this is super interesting look at the
bottom of the screen there
and look at how
back to school affects certain channels
you can see that the growth is kind of
the uh the viewership is kind of steady
and then all of a sudden it goes into
these dramatic spikes now of course that
the matter that depends on your
demographic your audience but as soon as
back to school hits there's peaks on the
weekends valleys during the week as
people are maybe spending less time on
youtube or students are spending less
time on youtube so it says many creators
also experience drops and views around
mid-august when their viewers go back to
school
now also it says recently we've seen
fluctuations in traffic related to code
vid which dramatically changed people's
viewing habits
and that's actually good news
from the pandemic we've been going
through a lot more people are on youtube
a lot more people are watching youtube a
lot of people learn to watch youtube a
lot of baby boomers and gen x are
watching more youtube now
and so
the punchline being though is the time
of year matters
a good test i learned from graham
steffen was this
if you're an established creator
and maybe five to ten of your
competitors or collaborators
are all declining a little bit and you
can use a software like vid iq to just
go to their stats and see they're down
10 or 15 subscribers they're down 10 or
15 views
if they're all down
and you're down as well channels that
are maybe in your similar channel
cluster
well
of course you never want to make excuses
you want to hustle and get results but
at least you have peace of mind that oh
it's maybe back to school oh it's maybe
some market change you know the market
is slow down the audience interest to
slow down
but
if everyone in your channel cluster is
actually going up and your stagnant or
going down that's a better indication
that you should check under the hood see
why your oil lights on and like shoot i
need to change the oil i need to pivot
what i'm doing
we try to never let we always try to say
what's in our control at think media
never say oh the market's down or this
we think about how can we get creative
how can we reinvent ourselves how can we
hustle how can we make our next best
video but uh holding intention a
gracious perspective for ourselves so we
can sleep good at night in terms of
yeah i mean it's the slower season of
the year like let's judge our year by
all 12 months and the cycles as opposed
to just one week because if you tie your
emotions too closely to your youtube
analytics then you're going to be riding
a roller coaster of highs and lows
that's probably pretty toxic for your
health at some point you have to
disconnect a little bit and also just
get a more wider perspective that has to
do with the four seasons and not just
one moment in your youtube channel's
history tip number four are you enjoying
this content
maybe share this video with somebody if
you're if you're loving this i'm so
grateful that i got to learn this from
todd uh bupre the
product manager at youtube
and uh these insights are super powerful
and number four
it's normal for viewers to discover
videos in different ways
this was one of my favorite moments
because here's what's happening in the
youtube
um
sphere lately right i don't know who
else you maybe watch that educates on
youtube people talk uh that aren't even
youtube educators about how they grew
their channel about the best way to grow
a channel and everyone has their
polarizing point of view or their their
opinions like
no you gotta make videos like mr beast
you gotta have
uh you gotta have a curiosity in the
title and you gotta have a crazy face in
the thumbnail and you gotta go after
search and recommend it
that's true
if your channel style theme and topic
is like mr beast and it's entertainment
based it's kind of viral based
but
the truth is this there's not one
tidy answer for every type of topic in
niche on youtube so some people
uh like to really put down youtube
search because honestly youtube search
is only about 15 of the traffic on
youtube youtube recommendations is about
75 of the traffic
but that's but todd didn't join any camp
oh i'm the youtube suggested camp i'm
the youtube search camp oh i'm i'm
playlists and whatever he said it
depends on the niche i had people coming
up to me at vidsummit and saying sean
what like what uh what traffic source
should i go after
when it comes to growing my youtube
channel i said that's the wrong first
question
i said
what is your overall goal
who is your audience what is your
business model what is it you're trying
to build and what is the best strategy
based on your channel topic and niche it
is not one size fits all and that was
proven
when pod showed us this
it's normal normal for viewers to
discover videos in different ways
so for example if you have an education
channel how to make french toast
then you're probably going to have most
of your traffic from search
okay and then some will be from the home
page and some will be from suggested
so if you have an education channel
and this gets even richer later like
this gets crazier in terms of the power
of search
now if you if you make chill beats to
study to and maybe you're making
copyright for you music you might get 50
of your views from playlists
30 from search 20 from suggested now if
you do world news today
trending topic trying to get on the
trending page topics hot click through
rate videos you're going to get 80 of
views from homepage you might just get
oh my gosh look at that headline and
that could be great for you but
sometimes those channels they have high
highs and low lows and their videos look
like this
and they go up and down whereas how to
make french toast by the way if you rank
for that that french toast video is
probably going to be watched
four years from now six years from now
maybe 10 years from now and a lot of
times a search channel creates a stable
business model that is not as dependent
on viral hits and you're only as good as
your last video
i'm not trying to emphasize one or the
other of course at think media we really
learn lean towards search and we get
around 3.5 million views every single
month whether we upload new content or
not because we've built a library of
videos that give us views while we
snooze and also allow us to honor our
biggest priority which is family so we
have time off family rest a sustainable
pace because we want to be at our best
and some people really want to hustle
and go for viral hit after hit all i'm
saying is just know
who you are know your ambitions know
your end goal no no know the business
model that you want to go after and so
it also supports our entire vision in
terms of our approach to how we do this
and so uh
remember the point being it's normal for
viewers to discover videos in different
ways
let me know what niche you're in and if
you want to go a little bit deeper on
today's coffee with cannel
drop in the comments if you go to your
youtube analytics and you go to your
traffic sources what is your biggest
traffic source for your channel and what
kind of niche are you in have you
noticed that if you are maybe making
skits or comedy or viral type hits that
suggested in home is your biggest thing
is search your biggest traffic source is
it a mix and
the other big idea is you can play in
multiple we just had a short go viral
got 2.8 million views
so that was suggested in home page
we have a video going right now blowing
up with browse features which is home
page and being recommended so actually
you can do multiple but it's also nice
to just know what is the
foundational approach of your channel
number five and i got a bonus tip number
six for you in just a second
the audience
is more important than the algorithm
is youtube's algorithm against small
channels
listen the youtube algorithm doesn't
even know you exist the youtube
algorithm
it's not whether or not it's for or
against you the youtube algorithm is for
the viewer
this is what it comes down to
of course
at some point your content or your
content does matter because your content
is being served to the viewer
but it's a whole wrong mindset to say
the youtube algorithm is against me
that's not even the conversation the
youtube algorithm is for
the viewer
the youtube algorithm is simply just
trying to put the audience first the
viewer first
listen to this quote
the goal of youtube's recommendation
system
is to find videos for viewers
not
viewers for videos
see i see this a lot
with youtube creators that are honestly
self-obsessed
they're looking inward why is the
youtube algorithm against me why does
the youtube algorithm not like me
conspiracy theorists why is the youtube
algorithm conspiring against small
youtube creators why does the youtube
algorithm not promoting me because it's
not about you what the youtube algorithm
is doing
is trying to find good videos for
viewers
the youtube algorithm is obsessed with
the audience
so your breakthrough moment in growing
your youtube channel could be that if
you stopped being obsessed with yourself
and you started being obsessed with the
audience
you stopped being obsessed with
victimhood of why is my channel not and
you actually started thinking about man
what audience am i trying to serve and
how do i just make valuable content that
satisfies those viewers if that becomes
your obsession if you think about the
audience first put the audience first
craft content for the audience first
you're gonna win on youtube
period
and that's how the youtube algorithm
works stated in their very own
words so here's the goal of the
algorithm
goal the algorithm is to help each
viewer find videos they want to watch
it's to maximize long-term viewer
satisfaction they want they do want you
to build a bond with an audience and the
people keep coming back and watching
your content
over or new videos you upload for
long-term satisfaction just like if you
fall in love are you are you team
seidfeld are you team friends
or are you team frazier that was a
little niche
uh because you think about it's like a
long-term journey like i feel like i am
friends with jerry's cycle you know what
i mean kramer is my my homeboy like i
would be surprised if you bust through
the door right now or maybe you're a
chandler bing guy you know or maybe
you're a ross and rachel i don't know
um but ultimately when you think about a
show like that you think about
long-term bond and maximizing long-term
viewer satisfaction i'm not talking
about a long viewing session i'm talking
about people falling in love with
youtube itself the creators on youtube
itself that is what youtube's after it's
after like building up that
that satisfaction so they have people
coming back to the platform
youtube said this
viewer satisfaction todd said this
viewer satisfaction is actually more
important than watch time and everything
the algorithm does is viewer centric
that's the goal of the algorithm and
this is kind of interesting because what
they showed us here was that back in
2011 this is a history of the algorithm
basically
was that back in 2011 it was about
clicks and views
but at that time it led to a lot of true
click bait because people would just
throw whatever in the thumbnail
they would throw whatever in the title
and just try to get some views but
satisfaction was super low because you
clicked on a video and you're like that
was a trick
you lost trust you're like annoyed you
lost some of your time so then what they
did is they fixed that and they started
to do watch time
so then they started seeing if someone
clicks and views it but they spend at
least a couple minutes on the video
they'll be even more satisfied
but today look it went from clicks and
views to watch time to satisfaction
ask viewers what they like and optimize
for what they like and they're talking
about surveys
and not all watch time is equal so
they're saying this has been the
evolution of the algorithm saying now
man it's about the viewer and i'm
telling you the more the creator who
understands the viewer best wins the
creator who if you understand the viewer
that would then also mean that you craft
your content to connect with the viewer
to serve the viewer to answer the
viewers questions to solve the viewer's
problems to entertain the viewer then
you're going to
trickle trigger the algorithm
and you're going to see growth wider and
more impactful than you could ever
imagine now i got tip number six for you
in just a second but woof we are deep in
coffee with kennel this is a deep dive
episode um let me know your aha moment
so far what are you going to apply from
these insights from a youtube employee
when it comes to changing your content
for the future hit like if you've been
getting value and again today's episode
is brought to you by
the think media podcast if you're loving
this kind of
deep dive strategy you're gonna love the
think media podcast it's not outdated
youtube advice it's the real stuff
that's working right now and every
tuesday we upload a new episode now you
can catch it on audio spotify google
android stitcher audible wherever you
listen to podcasts or just subscribe to
the youtube channel if you want a clean
and easy url to help you get there just
go to thinkmediapodcast.com
and that'll take you to the youtube page
turn on notifications and you can watch
the video version of the podcast every
new tuesday heather taurus myself and
the think media team are bringing you
real actionable youtube strategy to help
you build a full-time income doing what
you love with youtube our mission at
think media is to help 10 000
purpose-driven people create a full-time
living doing what they love while making
a difference in the world with online
video
we are not trying we are excited but
this is not hype we are passionate and
pumped up and and we like to write
powerful youtube titles that get clicks
but we hope that you experience real
substance real depth real tactics we are
obsessed with being player coaches here
at think media we're posting 10 videos a
week basically between two youtube
channels testing and experimenting
constantly surveying our community of
thousands of students to see what's
working and delivering the best
information to you because i believe
this this next decade is the best decade
to be growing a youtube channel
so far we have another tip from the
youtube employee but so far we've
learned it's not too late 600 million
videos different videos are being
recommended on the homepage every day so
with the right tactics and the right
skills and the right mindset building
your confidence getting your camera
dialed and creating compelling content
come on now it's time to grow your
youtube channel and uh i hope you could
be a part of the think media podcast
journey number six
this is some icing on the cake friends
remember the value of evergreen content
now again
if you've hung out with think media for
very long you know that this this one
gets me excited
now i am not trying to say that this
strategy fits every channel
again if you're news based
the news you share today is maybe only
valuable for what three days seven days
but it's not valuable a year from now
if you're entertainment based or you
really react to trends squid game's hot
at the time of recording this
but it'll probably be somewhat forgotten
it'll be a lot lower in three in a month
it'll probably be somewhat forgotten
unless season two comes out in six
months or a year
but remember the value of evergreen
content and i was shocked with everyone
so obsessed with with suggested videos
and kind of going viral about how much
todd emphasized
the value of evergreen content
and he said this
for a lot of content the majority of
views are not coming in the first day
month
or even the first year
i hope that
sent chills through your body what
chills like sean why are you trying to
give me chills on coffee with kennel
a lot of the content see this is a
mindset shift
are you creating quality content today
realizing that
the
a lot of the content
may not even
um
get a lot of views in the first
year
that's the power of evergreen content
and the question there is you ask
what is the lifespan of this content now
here's the thing obviously
i am passionate about search and i'm
passionate about evergreen content and
what does evergreen mean if you're new
to the term it's like an evergreen tree
if you grew up in seattle like me
there's trees that are green through
summer spring winter fall that's why
seasonality affects you less by the way
seasonality affects us less at think
media
we it's like you we just have this
crazy amount of about a quarter million
views that come in every two days
because this is the strategy we've
applied
that's also intentional it's also
sustainable
and and i'm passionate because youtube
is not everything
my faith and my family is everything so
i'm trying to build a youtube channel
that actually serves and supports my
lifestyle not the other way around i
don't live to serve youtube and a lot of
people fall into that trap and it's
leading to burnout because they're just
the the algorithm is running their lives
the algorithm the dopamine drip from
trying to get another one or trying to
get that next hit to try to keep it
going
so
a way to bring more stability into your
youtube strategy
is to think more evergreen and he
specifically todd was saying
how long will this video be relevant
when you post a video
will this video still be interesting to
viewers a year from now or even multiple
years from now
how widely appealing is this video and
will it be able to continue to be
searched and served to audiences
and in a future training
maybe i'll pull up like 15 different
examples we were just joking with omar
on the think media team because we post
a lot of videos on think media that
sometimes we're emotionally driven like
you we go crap it's so it's
underperforming oh the click-through
rate was terrible oh man it got the
views were so low i knew i hated that
thumbnail i knew that video was like oh
man i put so much work into that
and we were just studying one of omar's
videos
that literally did not climb through our
typical performance into high
performance
for over a year over
365 days and now the video has like 80
000 views but it's not stopping it was a
video about best lenses for a sony
camera
and so all of a sudden todd's words i
really start to be like man that is so
true
for a lot of content the majority of
views are not coming in the first day
month or even year this is a it's funny
the tension between between the two
strategies because for a lot of content
that is viral based and like recommended
based the majority of the views are
coming in the first week you're trying
to get a banger and i'm all for the
bangers you're trying to get the boom
views coming in you know uh
click-through rate's so crazy youtube's
telling you views are up 4x youtube's
views are up 8x more power to you
i think you should try to do both but
it's really nice to have a baseline of
videos on your channel that um get views
24 7 365 and let me actually show you
and i'll illustrate this with uh the
youtube short that just went viral on
think media and this is kind of crazy
because it's so shocking of what a a
quote-unquote banger can do
so here's
it's clear to see when the banger was
and it actually makes our typical daily
performance seem really
average and discouraging but think about
this here's here's how think media works
daily 110 000 views 109 000 views 114
000 views 106 000 views 103 000 views oh
up a little bit
you know 137 000 views and then nolan
made a short and after about 30 days the
short went viral boom
a million views in a day october 12th
now it's so fascinating and we'll report
back on this
is we have to wait to see if money comes
from the short fund
um shorts don't earn a ton of
monetization not that that's the whole
point but just something to consider
it did lead to like 7 000 new
subscribers which would be the high
impact of it but then look at look at
this climb imagine if your emotions were
tied to this i'm on top of the world
boom i am the worst person in the whole
world crash
just
and and that crash though but think
about this back to just 110 000 views a
day
and that's a lot of freaking traffic
so ultimately the one-two punch of the
youtube algorithm are you making
evergreen search-based content that
brings stability uh and sustainability
to your youtube strategy to your
business and then thank god for the
opportunity to have a viral breakout
video and and think about the impact
that that video makes a lot
of content for a lot of content the
majority of views don't come in the
first day month or even year so as we
land the plane
you got to stay committed to the vision
you got to keep putting in the work you
got to be willing to put out excellent
quality content today that you actually
have faith in because you go shoot
i i'm i'm making i'm crafting this video
i'm crafting it so it holds viewers
attention so that it's pleasing to watch
so i'm trimming the fluff so that it
gets to the point so that it answers the
question so that it solves the pain
point for the viewer
and
i'm putting it out there in the world
and then i'm getting to work again and
i'm gonna do it week after week after
week because i might not start really
reaping the rewards of this thing until
52 weeks from now
and then i'm really not going to start
reaping the rewards from this thing
maybe for even two to three years
but then all of a sudden
i have this like whoa i'm getting like a
thousand views a day
dang i'm getting like 10 000 views a day
wow i didn't know that that one video i
did because not every video will break
out like that but i didn't know that one
video i did is gonna do so well my gosh
but now it's like these videos are
working without me even working friend
that's the power of youtube
that is the power
of putting out strategic evergreen
content that gets views 24 7 365 whether
you actually post new videos or not
because you've built up a powerful
library of content
hit like if you're getting value today
this show is coffee with kennel and
click or tap the screen if you want to
watch our youtube domination framework
if you love this video you definitely
got to check out that video next because
we talk about the four areas uh and you
really want to be in the fourth one if
you're going to have sustainable growth
on youtube my name is sean cannell and i
cannot wait to see you in the next
episode so we will talk
soon
and that is how we repurpose a video
coffee with candle because that first
part will be chopped up i'm still here
the show is not ending it's just
starting and uh
and i'm didn't know that was gonna be
like an hour long but i hope you got
value let me know your uh aha moments
from that let me know what you're
drinking what's your uh eaten
and uh let me see this
does this mean that you won't see real
results of think media switch to daily
uploads until next year uh we're already
seeing the results from that um
but uh
and we're seeing it in so many different
levels
uh
but yeah the daily upload thing is is
pretty crazy and great observation for
noticing that that's uh happening what
was your aha moment today a coffee with
kennel what are you sipping on um i'm
i'm drinking some
vitamins uh those ones that come in a
little plastic capsule and then you mix
them in water and they like fizz out
um
yeah jay-z good to see you today jay-z
jay-z helps jay-z the rapper no the
letter is jay-z yeah i'd love to do
coaching someday when you're ready
melissa drinking peppermint tea cheers
uh the content output has been insane i
appreciate that of course teamwork makes
the dream work love and respect to
i mean
the whole think media team but the the
content arm we have someone helping full
time on uh thumbnails now his name's ian
crushing it tony is producing and kind
of like air traffic control for nolan's
videos coming in omar's video is coming
in steph's editing he's up in canada
chopping up
you know videos we're doing uh heather's
shooting videos we've got brand deals
it's really grown think media is 18
people now which is crazy y'all because
i'm just a small town kid college
dropout i started shooting videos in my
bedroom and i'm trying to figure out how
to be a ceo like i don't know what i'm
doing so thanks for your prayers um and
so uh drinking tea cheers
uh we're going to be bringing on some
guests today we got rob and marcus
coming up in just a second um on the
coffee with kennel show
uh we bring you on it's been a minute
last week we had brock johnson on or two
weeks ago i don't remember and uh i'm
excited to be back with you
it's a thousand degrees
in here so let me see
get a little air going
i'm so pumped up from the youtube
employee secrets
um
all right let's see we got a question i
know you mentioned making videos that
that can serve your niche but what if
you're working on widening your niche
because you're already on top of the
niche mountain
yeah it's a great idea i think when you
maybe have
kind of made a lot of videos around your
niche you ask what's related
and what could
but what is has broad audience appeal
and that's what todd said
you want to expand your youtube audience
create content
that has broad audience appeal let me
illustrate um we did a video on best
video editing software that's actually
not very broad
like very few people in the world will
ever want to edit video you know what i
mean
and then even more so
we'll specify down to final cut or
premiere now think about it and i'd love
to ask you like what do you use to edit
you know so people love filmora
hit film express vegas imovie
and so
that video just does not have broad
audience appeal
this is where people don't even
understand what we're really doing at
think media and how effective it is
because this is a great example of a
video that you actually can see it's
bare it's underperforming or it's at the
base of performance but we are not
judging it as todd product manager from
youtube told us by day one or even day
seven
right
we are judging it in fact let me i
mentioned those examples i'll just give
it to you
um
this is so crazy because
this is this is not the video but let me
see if this one
this video i didn't like the thumbnail
because it was um
i don't know i just i thought it was too
rainbowy color it was all right uh you
could but look how bad it underperformed
it's it's under even our typical
performance
but at day 99 it was still underneath
our typical performance
and then boom it cuts through but also
this huge gray this tells you that at
day 594
the average think media gets video gets
68 000 views
so we post a video today and people go
oh you only got 6 000 views i'm like
meet me at freaking 500 day 594 bro i'm
gonna have 68 000 views on that video
two years from now but nobody sees that
and if every video i post today and we
as a team post today has an average of
70 000 views in two years it means they
continue to be watched but it also means
that our library is like an investment
portfolio
that's going crazy and is a lot more
stable than crypto
um okay
so uh
with that though hit a little like if
you're fired up today on the coffee with
cannell uh and we're gonna bring rob on
let me actually
pull up rob's
info
um all right and uh
rob welcome to the coffee with kennel
show good to see you tell me a little
bit about where you're coming from and
what your channel is about my channel
was started to
help small churches with a limited
budget for their worship teams i've been
a guitar player and a drummer forever
and a day
serving at a very small church and
because of this i actually got hired by
another church uh to continue working
with their worship team
and my question is how on earth
as i'm trying to build this but this uh
business around budget worship leaders
and everything else is coming in and
taking up all of my time and i'm still
trying to focus and get these youtube
videos done it's like there's not enough
hours in the day and i know you always
say that you have the same 24 hours as
anybody else does
but it seems like the more i the more i
go in deeper with this the more things
show up that are just getting in the way
of doing my youtube channel
100 well rob thank you so much for
coming on uh coffee with kennel today
i've got a lot of
aspects of looking at this first of some
tips for your youtube channel then
there's maybe some tips for productivity
and then there's just general
perspective on your life season first
and foremost
um your youtube channel this is a great
niche just to speaking to today's topic
on on
uh
on total addressable market or audience
size you know the average church in
america is under 100 members it's under
maybe 80 members
so while there's certainly
a a chance for
channels to talk about like the nicest
guitars or the nicest pedals or the
fanciest gear or say even the mega
church
kind of culture
the average church is not that
so you have a chance not only to serve
and help people and accomplish an
incredible mission as you help the
majority the larger market that's in
need of
the practical everyday
budget-friendly type of worship
solutions um from a business standpoint
it's also smart because the total
addressable market is a lot bigger than
even say mega churches
um
secondly
i think that the answer to how much is
on your plate today and still succeeding
on youtube is evergreen content and we
have very similar i mean shockingly
similar stories because i worked at a
church i was not only an intern and
part-time staff from like 2003 to 2009
but then i came to vegas and joined
full-time staff as a director of
communications from like 2011
to 2015.
and so i was in the same boat with you i
get it the ministry is the priority
loving people building up teams raising
up leaders you probably work 30 40 50 60
hour weeks how do you have time do you
have a family
i'm a father of five yeah so i mean i
mean come on like people are feeling it
in the comments right now they're like
dear god
like father of five
church responsibilities growing church
trying to you know raise up leaders and
then do youtube
so
before we get into the productivity tips
one is just kind of having a gracious
perspective
and recognizing the season of life
you're in it's kind of it's going to be
very difficult to build
at a high level a youtube channel
while juggling all those life
responsibilities but
the answer is throughout the year when
you have time
to make really smart videos
that get views
whether or not you post new videos or
not and that is exactly what i was doing
through
um all through 2010 to 2015 on think
media and a lot of people i've never
shared this before um but if we look at
the history here
even from day one 11 years ago in 2010 i
was talking about how to build a video
editing pc because my video experience
goes back all the way to 2003 and the
video got 10 000 views now mind you
that's also over 10 years and i'm sure
people dig around on the old content to
laugh at me and mock my journey
um but see i was understanding youtube
as a search engine in the power of
evergreen content a decade ago
so whether or not i
you know video blogging tips and tricks
got 21 000 views so when i had a little
extra time
i would make a video
on my way to work by the way this is me
uh and and i believe that production
standards are higher today and uh there
there's old sean uh
with the hoodie and like a hd flip
camera
so but i would put these videos out and
i'd do them around strategic topics this
is a great one i was teaching on gear
and this one got 59 000 views and was
connected to affiliate marketing so i
started to earn 20 bucks a month 50
bucks a month 100 a month
and this is the worst shot poorly lit
video in youtube's history but because
it answered a specific problem it still
you know added a lot of value and so you
can see
this whole journey was me doing this on
the side
i had a uh a full and and if you
actually study
the videos are not weekly sometimes
they'd be once a week sometimes they
would be more than that and sometimes
i'd take like a month off people put too
much pressure on themselves
in terms of
and
um
i also
made a lot of videos that didn't have as
much evergreen value so it was i learned
during this season that some videos
when you're in your situation five kids
full-time job
you need to be very selective and you
want to be applying the 80 20 rule and
just making the 20 of videos that get
eighty percent of the results
when when
you know mom takes the kids for for all
day saturday you get a couple you get a
couple good videos done
when you get some time off at work spend
half your time resting and have your
time creating some content and here's
the key you don't know what the future
is going to hold and and the nice thing
about this is this actually the
insurance everybody listening to this
the world is too disruptive it's almost
like it's almost like you can't afford
not to be building a side hustle
i mean lockdowns could happen and
churches could close their doors and
that's out of your control you know and
then you're laid off uh there is no
security in in corporate america there
is no security with our jobs i'm not
trying to scare anybody but the reason
you want to be taking a portion of your
side hustle time you know even if you
got a family is if you do what i'm
saying now it's exactly what i did from
2010 to 2015.
when i jumped out and started think
media full-time i had 16 000 subscribers
i had
a lot of skills i had learned and i had
a base of discoverability because i had
been
arguably
inconsistent in the week to week
but consistent over a five year period
of posting videos when i could
and a breakthrough moment happened when
i posted you wanna talk about 80 20 rule
when i posted best camera for youtube
eight years ago the video got 226 000
views the um
it generated a ton of money with
affiliate marketing turned into a series
and i continued to make videos like this
and this is the opportunity for you so
you need to be making the most strategic
videos for worship leaders uh that are
on a budget that are about the most
searched and most influential evergreen
top topics that have a long shelf life
and then what happens is maybe
eventually you can hire an editor
because yes you do have the same 24
hours in the week but
you now have some money coming in so you
can hire an editor
uh you
go part-time at church something some
transition happens and you're ready for
this to become your full-time business
you won't be ready if you're not
chipping away at it now but you will be
ready if if you kind of do the strategy
i'm i'm proposing um and that is
ultimately
the kind of content i would create on
youtube the grace i would give yourself
in the moment for not being overly
judgmental if you don't post for three
weeks but then number three being really
committed to
uh putting out quality videos when you
can realizing evergreen wise those will
get better over time and who knows how
those will position you for your future
but they will be an investment that your
future needs if you want more insurance
financially
influence-wise to be able to open doors
for other opportunities um because those
very things i've lived over the last
decade was that helpful at all rob does
that absolutely and and i didn't get
hired full-time by the church i have a
full-time job plus i got hired by the
church for their worship team
dude that's i feel you though because i
mean 2009 i'm working at red robin i'm
working at the church i started my
business clear vision media
key
i didn't have five kids
the five kids thing rob you got a whole
nother dinette you know right now i've
got a one-year-old but but our
one-year-old uh has been i think media
was already over 10 team members and
it's still crazy and we're still asleep
and like trying to run a business and
all that stuff but season of life is
really real and so i definitely want you
i mean of course there's all the tactics
bro you gotta have a lot of grace for
yourself and it's just like a realistic
perspective and i think you know what i
mean dude five kids full-time job
part-time church side hustle when do you
find time for it all um you know final
thing i'll recommend it'll be a resource
we'll link this up in the description
um
a really good
maybe one of the better books i've read
lately
is called at your best by my friend
carrie new off and it's how to get
time energy and priorities working in
your favor
and um man it's super super good i
highly recommend it i've been listening
to the audiobook i'm digging through the
uh the physical book um carrie also has
a podcast i was
a leadership podcast and he's really
into
um
productivity tips for leaders church
leaders his background he was a pastor
for like 20 years so
uh that also you know you're like i
don't got time to write a book man i'm
trying to do everything or read a book
but you know if you're on walks or
whatever maybe grab the audiobook of at
your best on audio because
that's the final piece and that's what a
lot of heather taurus teaches in at
think media
is
man it's priorities it's how it's kind
of how bad do you want it not with like
a toxic hustle energy to it but like a
gracious energy to it but it's like
what am i willing to give up
how what am i am i willing to change my
sleep and diet because i need
world-class energy world-class focus
world-class time management world-class
prioritization world-class systems and
calendaring in my life i need to learn a
whole new skill set if i'm going to
effectively
parent five kids
work at my job
steward a ministry and what i'm doing
part-time at a church and then also
build a side hustle the interesting
thing is if somebody else is doing it so
can you
you just have to be asking yourself are
you willing to pay the price they're
paying um and learning the disciplines
and skills they've learned to do it
and uh i think that book will help you
it's called at your best by kerry new
off
thank you
absolutely rob did was today valuable oh
absolutely
hey i appreciate you and i love what
you're doing man i love your heart and i
love the vision of your channel i
appreciate you sean all right take care
yeah
my friends do you feel like you've got a
little bit too much on your calendar my
friend javen postal is here in the
comments today man
throwback jaybin we he used to uh we
hired him for a couple trips we'd we'd
fly up to canada we'd shoot conferences
back when we did this thing called think
international he knows the hustle days
he knows the grind uh i think the hustle
days are still here jabin uh awesome
father video production uh legend and uh
if you don't know javen postal barbecue
one of the early video ranking academy
students posted a video um
barbecue accessories and uh posted a
video
uh for like father's day barbecue
accessories has made thousands by now in
affiliate marketing he's gotten a free
meat sponsor because he had a barbecue
channel locally in canada was working on
his own spice rub line has been given
free grills free whatever the power of
building a channel in a particular niche
and then companies want to send you
stuff uh definitely check out postal
barbecue we got chris johnson a house
hey good to see you man uh thanks for
coming on coffee with kennel
today good times man i remember those
days
i this is why my beard turned gray was
the hustle over the the last 10 years
and uh some of the the grind full time
since 2020
wow bro congratulations
uh daisy we need to tell chris about
that that's a that's a sick journey full
time
since last year
we're on a mission to help ten thousand
people go full time with a barbecue tub
line i imagine that's probably rubline
unless it's a tub line
boom i wish i had a sound effect machine
only the seattle office has that right
now and so uh
okay thanks for the super chat uh let me
see
i can't see it let me hang on
um
it's not only 18 people it think it's a
whole nation
where would we be without you and your
team thank you you've helped me so much
dude
thank you so much for those kind words
that's super powerful think nation
have you been how long you've been a
part of this journey um and you know
from my heart sincerely uh thank you for
those kind words and also
you know i heard john maxwell put it
this way
in the early days as a leader you know
the first few steps you take as a leader
are often alone
you might feel that way right now
your first few steps into starting a
youtube channel there's probably nobody
cheering you on nobody else sees the
vision you see
nobody else no one's really encouraging
you you got to encourage your step
yourself the first few steps you take as
a leader are oftentimes alone
and what ends up happening
is
in my early days building a youtube
channel i probably got less credit than
i deserved
and you're probably getting the same
because people don't see the late nights
they don't see the stress and the
anxiety they don't see that the comets
that get under your skin
they don't feel the pressure
of what it means to actually create
something when you could just be
consuming constantly
when the average american or the average
person around the world is spending
almost all their time consuming
you have the courage to be a creator but
you're not getting accolades for it no
one's giving you applause for it and in
the early days of the price i've paid to
get where i am today i probably get less
credit than i deserve
but the truth is today
now that
i broke through
and we the team has broke through i
probably get more credit than i deserve
and i learned that from john maxwell now
it's like dude think media sean like
what look what you know what's happening
and i'm like no look what the team's
doing
i'm like this it's incredible to see
where would we be without heather taurus
where would we be without omar el tacori
where would we be without chris and andy
and daisy loving on inner circle and
video ranking academy in our community
where would we be without john and
isaiah helping with brand deals where
would we be without kyle building battle
stations and editing some of the best
videos in the world and so that's kind
of the journey of leadership early on
you're going to probably get less credit
than you deserve
and the goal would be someday not that
that's the goal but you'll probably
start getting more credit than you
deserve because a team will build around
you and people don't necessarily see all
the work they're doing and i share that
with you just so i can publicly honor
the think media team and just say
uh that there's i did not get here alone
i did not build this by myself i may
have started this by myself but it is no
longer there's no i in team
but there's an eye in win
what i heard that quote somewhere i
don't know where we're going sean jay-z
in the house uh how do i add this on
screen thanks for the super chat we got
another uh coffee with kennel guests
coming on
sean if you were a person personal
injury lawyer what path would you take
on youtube
i like handling a small amount of big
injury cases but i gladly take whatever
opportunities uh youtube opportunities
offer jay-z i don't um
uh first of all you have my favorite
initials but second of all
um
i don't have anything that comes top of
mind here's what i would do i would
study
emily baker so look her up write these
down emily baker and her community the
law nerds and the live streams she's
doing
i would study uh
uh
erica kohlberg
she's a lawyer not personal injury but
you look at what she's doing she was
able to pay off college debt with the
youtube videos she was making
i would study
mitch jackson the social media lawyer
and what he's doing not as much on
youtube but i think his youtube channel
and he wrote a book on law for social
media
and then i would study mark j kohler on
youtube um who does a lot of stuff about
setting up llc's he's probably the most
and then of course there's like legal
eagle there's another one so there's
like five
uh
law
legal channels
and that's what i would do and then for
everybody watching
that prescription right there is a
really smart way to start building out
your game plan
is to say okay
i know i'm going to be in law
who who's out there that i should follow
and and you may not even searching might
be hard to find them so it's good that
you ask me because i can point you to
people um but that would be my goal
friends is what are five channels you
could kind of learn from brainstorm from
success leaves clues and so don't try to
reinvent the wheel even though
eventually you'll bring some originality
and creativity to the wheel i'm sure
start with what's working start with
some of the players that are having
success study their moves study their
videos and that'll give you a great
starting point for
making an impact hey super chat's coming
in appreciate it uh your grind is
contagious god bless and infinite thanks
for not giving up i really really
appreciate that mar uh
caribbe and uh uh
man just grateful god is good and uh
pumped to be here all right we got
another guest on coffee with kennel
today marcus is back on the channel
marcus remind us who you are what
channel uh you're doing and uh what's
your question today
absolutely so i got
my name my channel name is the same as
what you see on the screen marcus sepula
it is communication tips and i
previously branded it as communication
tips from a comedian but i found out
that
the communication tips more related to
zoom and hybrid meetings actually seem
to be
giving me the most growth
and
the last time i was on the show you
said one thing that has stuck in my mind
so how are you i said that i had
probably at that time maybe five videos
about hybrid meetings so when you
combine in-person and online meetings
and you said okay so you are the world's
number one authority on hybrid meetings
and i said okay i am so i started making
i probably now have about 20 videos
about that topic
which um the the cpms are amazing
they're like in the 50s 60s cpm on that
there we go
yeah so it's it's like a very high uh
high earning topic because i think
there's a lot of demand
but not a lot of supply as far as i
understand
but so what's working great is the cpms
what's working great is affiliate
conversion and what's working great is
email conversions however my growth has
stopped
so i had very steady growth from june of
last year until june of this year but
now it's been stuck at 40 000 views per
month approximately
and
i thought first it was a summer
slump
but
now i'm kind of wondering what would be
a strategy to
to regain some of that growth and one
thing i've done based on your
recommendation in the past is the um
what is the saying again
successfully leaves clues make part twos
so i made a lot of part twos that's the
the one strategy i've tried so far
well marcus this is a great conversation
for a lot of people that could relate
what do you do when your growth has
stopped what do you do when your channel
is stagnated
and what i would do is i would start
first asking a couple questions
one i would ask um what's happening in
my overall market
and
while
remote meetings hybrid meetings are
certainly here to stay
um there's no doubt that we are
definitely we're getting back to the new
normal uh but people are kind of going
back to work the the the peaks of the
pandemic are leveling out um we talked
about it recently with the think team um
a lot of creators are having withdrawals
from essentially
the uh
extreme amount of views they got from
the pandemic world that they took credit
for that was not
as a result of them as a result that
people had nothing else to do and then
they're they're misinterpreting the fact
that that crash has happened so we our
views doubled on think media as soon as
the lockdown started makes sense people
came home and they started like
searching stuff they're like i got
nothing to do should i what camera
should i buy how do i get what's the
best lighting you start asking questions
that went up through the pandemic and
then it dropped now
what i think we have to at least be
somewhat so that's what i'm saying what
are the external market dynamics
um i think that
you also should acknowledge
you need more views right because you're
trying to earn enough money
correct
so
if
you're you need to grow
to reach the plate of full for to reach
a place of full-time and sustainability
and i know this is not helpful to you
helpful to you but just look at it from
my perspective
we went into incredibly prosperous times
just because
people were watching tons of youtube
that crashed what i do as a strategist
is i try to never
um i try to remain grounded in the midst
of
all of those potential emotional highs
it what it's what happens if somebody
gets like a windfall of money into their
business and they go sweet let's lease a
bunch of company cars let's do this
let's do that they get over leveraged
then the crash happens i'm i i actually
try to live with a really conservative
mindset and actually live in 40 40 views
40 000 views a month is the baseline and
by the way that's that's something to
really applaud yourself for you know
it's kind of like i am
you know i'm failing no like you're back
to just what normal is like normal and
it's it's okay like
40 000 views there's so many people
watching coffee with kennel right now
that would literally like put their
sister's hand in a bowl of hot water
while she's sleeping until she cleans
the bed just to get you know 40 000
views a month
of course we want to evolve past that
but there's something about the sober
thinking of coming back down to a
baseline
of
uh
of of the market dynamics so what are
the market dynamics are hybrid meetings
just not even dying but just stabilizing
and
also
are you perfectly positioned
for the next wave so that's the other
thing is like
like uh an owl at night
hunting for
you know a badger do owls go after
badgers you're just waiting in the tree
man because
the world's so unpredictable and weird
and scary maybe there's more lockdowns
maybe there's going to be more remote
pivots nobody could have like planned
for the pandemic
uh although some people call it a
pandemic
yeah maybe not
get into that
and
but but nevertheless again so it's
almost like think media i was just
working 10 years for the for for having
a library of videos ready for when
people couldn't leave their houses
so you're also potentially setting
yourself up for the future next thing um
and so it's number one it's kind of
thinking about what are the external
factors number two it's maybe about just
being okay and realizing this is more of
a sober healthy baseline and anything
above this is bonus in terms of your
niche but then number three and i think
the most important question for you and
all of us should be continually asking
this
what is next
how am i reinventing myself
do i need to up level my market like the
question earlier or widen my market
do i need to broaden my appeal
do i need to pivot pivot my topic
choices
what is coming down the road that i
could position myself now
uh for
you know
i'm not suggesting any of this but
what's happening with blockchain or
crypto or nfts what's happening with vr
or ar
augmented reality uh me virtual meetings
in an ar world
some of those things actually probably
aren't even as close as we think but are
those things you're pivoting towards and
positioning yourself towards
or
what in the present market and present
video topics that you may pivot into
the truth is
the nature of entrepreneurship
is there's a book by
uh the ceo former ceo of intel the chip
maker and the title of the book is
called only the paranoid survive
now i believe we should have peace like
a river enjoy like a fountain you know
it's in terms of our faith and the
anchor of our soul
but i also think as an entrepreneur
paranoia is a superpower because only
the paranoid survive who's putting this
out of business where's the market going
next where's cash flow coming from and
that's what i think your channel needs
it needs you need to reinvent and i
would i would say this
you are being kind of forced to reinvent
to grow from 40 000 views a month to 80
000 views a month
but everybody listening to this that's
comfortable right now at all then you're
in the worst position because you might
have been riding a wave that you were
taking credit for
as opposed to actually deepening your
skills
sharpening your craft positioning for
the next thing up leveling the thing
that you're doing
and you know any thoughts on that marcus
like is that a aha moment of what you
maybe need to do next
the uh uh
you mentioned vr and ars communication
forms that could be uh that could be an
interesting trend to to explore and a
lot of these virtual meetings have these
like virtual meeting rooms where you can
walk around just a little character in a
game for example that could be one topic
uh to have a look at
uh
the other
the other direction would be to go back
to
more
in-person based communication tips like
the reason why i originally started the
channel was that i wanted to share
communication tips from a comedian as
you know how to introduce a speaker how
to thank a speaker how to ask for
applause how to ask audience questions
these things and those never took off
but potentially they could now that
we're going back from lockdowns that
could be another opportunity potentially
i agree and and i would say the mode
right now marcus is rnd right it's the
rn it's back to research and development
it's back to experimentation it's
getting
getting the lab coat on and getting back
into the okay like you just said some
other topics to experiment with the
final thing i'll say is that just as we
talked about in the training earlier and
if you're just joining don't miss the
hour-long training that we started with
today a lot of gold in there and
insights from a youtube employee
your audience size
right your tam your total addressable
market is extremely small
so
that it would be the aha moment
of
depending on your ambitions for the
channel is just reverse engineering back
from am i in not only a total
addressable market that's large enough
for my youtube ambitions but also what
is my difference in that
in terms of of being able to create
content here's the good news
you
are uh incredibly i mean you have 3 000
subscribers you have a lot of channel
authority you have 142 videos you have
daily traffic
you have
subscribers that can click on new videos
that you upload
you are so powerfully positioned
um
for making some growth moves you know
what i mean you're obviously you're not
just starting but a lot of people are
they should just start right now but
that's a big mountain to climb you've
been putting in the work you've been
getting the you've been you've been
posting the videos you've been you know
doing all this kind of stuff i just want
to encourage you that i would really go
into
um
some r d some research and development
some strategizing and some deep thinking
and and even more specifically
market research
so
it's one thing to just say oh yeah maybe
i should experiment with ar no actually
do keyword research on it do google
trends research on it do some deep
reading and articles do do some deep
reading study go into some deep study of
of what other channels that are talking
about meetings hybrid meetings
i think that's the move because you're
at this moment right now
to take a few days or a weekend
to
determine what are going to be your next
couple moves for this next season and my
thought is on the other side of smart
strategy and smart execution you're
going to absolutely crush it because
you're building on a really good
foundation that you've built up into
this point
i appreciate that thank you thank you
very much it's r d weekend coming up
come on research and development i
appreciate you marcus thanks for coming
on the show thanks for having me
coffee with cannell hit the like button
if you like uh
hanging out today and um let me know
where are you watching from in the world
i'm coming to you from las vegas
and um
let me know
where you are
uh and
i appreciate you being here for some of
this q and a the coffee with kennel show
happens typically every other week for
the first 15 apparently to an hour uh i
do a training
a quick training um and something that
you can take action on implement um then
we do q a and if you have a text
question the way we do it here is you
post four question marks before and
after the question so it's really clear
in chat that it's a question and then we
also bring guests on um in the back end
um i'm gonna check my calendar here in a
second and see
uh what i'm up against next and
today i um um also on daddy duty in a
couple hours here so i've got a few
things i got to get ready but man i'm so
grateful that you are here today from
all over florida
los angeles
illinois clay in fort worth texas
india in the house new mexico in the
house new york
we've got maryland in the house
super grateful
for you being here today and on the
think media account we have daisy from
the think media team
joining us
from
hawaii
um radical marketer vegas in the house
hey good to see you you know
we're getting back to stuff in vegas um
we do these things called vegas
influencers
they stop during the pandemic but i'm
also excited because did you know that
march 23 through the 24th in las vegas
gary vaynerchuk the fake media team
and a lot of speakers soon to be
announced
are
are going to be
uh at the m hotel for our event called
grow with video live in las vegas if
you're not on the waiting list uh
tickets are not available yet but if
you're not on the waiting list you could
go to growwithvideolive.com
and daisy
will uh drop a link in the chat so you
could check that out as well and let's
also update that in the youtube
description so people can find
information about going to grow with
video live i appreciate you marcus
thanks so much
for
coming on again there's the url
grow with
video
live
dot
com
um
let me see
if
you were censoring people just for
asking questions would you be looking
for other platforms
i don't know if i understand the
question the way it's worded
but um i think diversifying is a good
idea my friend jp sears um his content
is not
big tech doesn't necessarily love it and
so there is actually a youtube
alternative he's just doing both
um you know there's other social
networks where there are alternatives
so
you know shouldn't we be looking for
other platforms um
am i i'm not we're not that
controversial here you know what i mean
what's the best camera for youtube i
mean maybe some stuff i say is
controversial but it depends on if
you're talking politics or you're
um talking it depends on your niche and
your strategy but i'll tell you this you
should not be putting all your eggs in
one basket well sean aren't you going
pretty hard on youtube we are but it's
why we build an email list and i hope
you get our emails
i hope you know if you ever sign up for
a web class or whatever that's pretty
much how you get on our email list
um that's our way to communicate with
you and talk with you if the youtube
algorithm or notifications don't go out
you know
um i hope that you maybe follow me on
instagram at sean cannell as it says in
the corner of the screen here
but again i i don't want to depend on
instagram or youtube i want to be
diversified uh and then i also want to
be diversified off of platforms and i
also want to encourage you if you go oh
there's so much to do is my next
priority to start a website build an
email list and be on every social media
platform it's probably not your next
priority
but you should always be steering the
ship and it's almost like just good
investing you're always hedging a little
bit or if your crypto accounts going up
you should cash out a little here and
there uh just just as a little hedge you
know
you never want to bet the whole farm you
know you you uh
want to be diversified strategically and
smartly
uh tech tweak says i've got a 10 to 11
ctr yet i'm struggling is there any tips
for me
ctr
is
kind of deceiving
so
the problem with ctr
it when you isolate it you go i got 10
to 11 percent
shouldn't that just be the magical
you know bean that i plant and creates a
beanstalk so i can climb into the clouds
like jack and the beanstalk
maybe but the problem is it's only one
factor
so here's what's hap here's what happens
text tweak is actually
if you have a smaller channel and a few
subscribers
you can have insane click-through rates
some people are like i got a 35
click-through rate i got a 67
click-through rate
which congratulations but like that
if if 100 people see it and 67 people
click on it but only only 67 people ever
click on it well then you got 67 views
so you could say am i celebrating my
click-through rate or am i actually
celebrating the macro bigger reach of my
entire video
so what ends up happening is the more
views a video gets it drives down the
click-through rate because youtube is
suggesting it and it's getting so many
impressions
if the click-through rate holds at like
a four four and a half or five percent
and it's getting millions and millions
of impressions then five percent is
amazing we have videos that get like a
2.5 click-through rate but the videos
have millions of views
so even todd from youtube the employee
was like yeah click-through rate is
almost like dirty data he's like it's
very important and you want to raise it
but there's there's like 18 perspectives
how big of a topic are people interested
in how many people is it being served to
how big is your audience um and at the
end of the day
the savvy youtube creator
is learning
to create an amalgamation and alchemy
of
all of the youtube analytics
and then drawing conclusions from that
it's thinking about what are the views
what is the watch time what is the
click-through rate what is kind of the
engagement rate are people even making
it are they clicking on the end cards
is it a one-off video or is it actually
part of my cohesive strategy
um because again you get one viral video
that's getting you a bunch of
subscribers and and you're trying to
reach people that are millennials but
you had a viral video
that is reaching a ton of 13 year old
gen z kids that's awesome but it's not
even accomplishing your mission it's
vanity metrics
so to a point and i'm not trying to say
that's a
whatever but
it's sort of meaningless in isolation
great it's a really good click-through
rate but obvious that's why you could be
struggling because you need an alchemy
of a lot of different youtube uh
analytics all combined um in an overall
youtube strategy that is going to help
you win
all right uh should you post shorts and
long form content on the same channel i
think you should just experiment
i think that
um
the first thing to do with almost any of
your questions if you're wondering
something like that try it
one short is not going to kill your
channel four shorts is not going to kill
your channel
but but experiment and then evaluate the
results what did you learn
did people leave comments on it because
it'll be served on desktop where a lot
of people and and and maybe mobile it'll
be subs it'll be served to your
subscribers first
not probably to the shorts feed first
and so see if it if it offends or annoys
your audience
if if it's only one comment don't let
that be an indicator of if it gets 500
likes and mostly positive comments but
one person's like i don't like that this
is well then you still might want to
move forward because it's only one
person but if it gets 50 dislikes and
people are like keep with the long form
then let that inform you so i would
recommend keep it on the same channel
experiment and then pivot
from there and here's the final thought
and this is what we've learned on think
media
so long as your short delivers on the
same promise for why people subscribe to
your channel it shouldn't disappoint
anybody even if they watch it on desktop
mobile even their smart tv
because
like we have videos they happen to be
vertical
so there's black on the sides people can
watch them on desktop we know that
because we also get desktop monetization
from them
but they might share like five cool
accessories for your smartphone
so if someone clicks subscribe on think
media they're like this is a great short
valuable video like that's what we've
learned they're like if the video is
good and it answers the question quickly
or adds value quickly and it just
happens to be a youtube short
people are not too disrupted by it
let me know what your opinions are
though i'd love to ask you think media
especially if you watch our think media
channel and you've seen us poach uh post
shorts that annoy you did that offend
you did you not care did you not even
notice
what's your philosophy
final takeaway though just test and
experiment
and uh and then and then let that inform
what you do
next
uh should you post clips from your live
streams on the same channel yeah why not
um experiment
i mean test and experiment with it it'd
be kind of like the joe rogan podcast
idea no no no no
first of all he's on spotify now but
back in the day when his three hour
episodes were on youtube he had a
separate channel called jreclipse which
you're suggesting is it's only one
channel i think you should experiment
and keep it on one channel especially
when you're earlier on in your journey
and the reason why is because when
someone sees the replay value of like
this video when someone's a replay value
of this video at this moment is 95
minutes long it's an hour
and 35 minutes long
the audience retention curve of this
very coffee with candle livestream is
going to be pretty terrible you know and
i mean it'll it'll be decent during the
first training and then it'll kind of
flatten out some people will watch the
whole thing because i think they get
value out of these questions and the
nuances and maybe turn it on while
you're working or while you're walking
the dog
etc so you'll get maybe like five or ten
percent will watch until the entire end
of it but throughout this very video
there's one question one answer there's
specific moments that would actually
serve
the think media podcast channel better
if they could get straight to that four
minutes of information or eight minutes
of information or whatever
so we happen to cut out clips we will
cut out clips from this video and we
post it on a separate channel our think
media channel
but i think if i'm you i would post it
all on the same channel because you're
kind of serving two different types of
people people who like the long form
live stream and then some people who
just want to
uh catch the highlights and then maybe
once it you are at scale
um
and what does that mean i think once you
have at least
10 at least 1000 subscribers but maybe
maybe even 100 000 you start thinking
then i should maybe start a second
channel and here's the big idea
do not spread yourself too thin too soon
if you try and chase two rabbits you end
up catching neither your goal is to get
really clear on one you i'm talking to
everybody here
what is your one big idea strong youtube
channel idea what is your strategy for
growing that youtube channel your
content calendar it could be a live
stream on tuesday and then three clips
from that live stream you commit to that
strategy great topics great ideas great
videos blow your channel up and then
once you reach 100 000 subscribers or
whatever
um
then pick your head up from you're
swimming head down
come on finding nemo just keep swimming
then eventually you look up gasp for air
and go okay what's my next move
too many people i think get distracted
by starting multiple channels too soon
one quick example for this is
uh my friend ruslan who only has one
channel
and what he does and here you go here's
an hour and a minute video
and then he cuts out like four things
okay so
here let's show let's do another one 48
minutes eight minutes six minutes and so
he does longer shows longer live streams
and then he cuts out multiple clips
and he uploads them all in the same
channel and he's at 100 000 subscribers
if you want to dig deeper into his
content too he has kind of a cool way to
do it meaning
he records his longer show
knowing ahead of time what the clips are
going to be
so he even has a little like bumper that
he plays and then he goes into a clip
and then he can edit that clip down a
little bit but he has a whole system for
it that's that's pretty cool and it's
really worked to
grow
his
channel all right we're gonna have one
more guest on here today we got uh
brandon in the house and uh brandon uh
welcome to the coffee with kennel show
our family bee uh brandon tell me where
you're watching from and uh what's your
channel all about hey sean we are in
west palm beach florida and our channel
is literally changes niches changing
niches this week uh because you have
been preaching niching down
the whole time we've been running this
channel and we thought we did it just
wasn't enough our audience ended up
being moms and so our content is going
to be simple living for busy moms
i love it simple living for busy moms
okay
and uh what's your question today
well
i wonder how we can do it better man
honestly so uh we started out doing i'm
a pastor my wife works in ultrasound we
started out doing content about marriage
and faith and finance and all the things
the family might care about
but we got a shout out from some bigger
creators and we got all these
subscribers who didn't care about any of
those things
so we are trying to narrow it down we
met with some of those folks who did
some surveys found out what they wanted
and they want they want costco hauls and
frugal living and organization tips and
that's okay because it's mostly my wife
because she's way better looking than me
which makes perfect sense yeah but my
question to you man is doing that we're
gonna put some of the other content on
other channels so we have a creative
outlet for that but
looking at what you're seeing there uh
what pops out at you as a red flag
something we may have missed because we
think we're reading the candle book but
we might be missing something man
well brandon thank you for coming on and
i think
first of all think community you gotta
just realize brandon dropped some
serious bombs just there the first one
was he got shouted out from some bigger
channels and it didn't do anything
some of you watching right now
some of you watching right now think
that that's that like if only i would
get you know shouted out it actually
that's actually i've seen that across
the board
it's sometimes cool it sometimes brings
in a little viewership it sometimes kind
of feels cool but it never is like the
light it does never it will not build
your business it does not establish you
it comes and it goes
the only thing that really works on
youtube is putting in the work over time
strategically and
also you know who they are but to your
point you said your audience didn't care
they're like i don't know
or whatever so um that's uh that's just
an encouraging thing to say hey don't
worry about like a shout out being the
answer or secret to you winning secondly
you asked your audience
all i'm doing is echoing your points for
the think community first here
you actually said hey
what is it you want the creator who
understands the viewer best wins hey
what kind of content did you want and
you were willing to put the viewer first
you were willing to say if the algorithm
follows the viewer it's not just the
videos we want to make it's the videos
that of course are combined with that
you're going to have a creative outlet
as you said over here but you're
thinking if we really want this thing to
grow we're going to really get in touch
with the audience those are two unlocks
uh think community that i'd love for you
to apply and then lastly i would just
affirm
uh that you're doing that i mean i think
that um
ultimately
uh
we don't
how long have you been doing the new
strategy
uh a few weeks man we just really kind
of narrowed this down literally friday
we're also we're putting up a video
announcing that we're changing the
channel name to my wife's personal name
beckley is the channel name i've got the
domain for her for me personally for us
together uh
so yeah that new strategy is just
narrowing down this week and dude yeah
it's good we good we're doing this stuff
but we learned it from you and you can
see we had some videos go really well
now listen when i do searchable content
like you taught us okay when i do the
work uh we'll make a cold brew video
that you know to uh a year and a half
later it's made us hundreds of dollars
and it's got 30 some thousand views
right that's a win people buy cold brew
filters like you wouldn't believe it
right okay uh we do a video on how to
cut a steak and i get the right keywords
we do a video on all these things i can
make searchable content we're actually
struggling more on the other side
we need to teach youtube what we're
about and unconfuse it so that it knows
which viewers are contents appropriate
for does that that's clear yeah yeah
yeah yeah so
um today
here's your game plan first of all
big warning first of all when you get
clear and confident on a new strategy
you've done the work you know you want
to make a pivot
you're only a couple weeks into it let
me just call out and for anybody here
this is a huge mistake we make and i
make it too
we we think we want to do a new strategy
we think we want to go in a new
direction we go in the new direction a
few weeks pass
and and and sometimes we start second
guessing like crazy
do not second guess too soon when you
pick a new strategy you have to give it
enough time and you mentioned time and
ministry uh or being you know being a
ministry i remember this churches i've
been a part of where we'd have like a
leadership consultant come in
and they would give us a new approach
zero times did we ever give it enough
time to even work what would happen is
you know what i mean give us a new
approach we would try it for a weekend
two weekends three weekends a month we'd
be like ah it's not working we throw it
out that is not enough time
so you have to actually kind of
disconnect your emotions from it and say
yes we do need to evaluate if this new
pivot was good or not but we're just not
gonna know
and and then the problem is
we also might make it a self-fulfilling
prophecy the reason it doesn't work is
because a couple weeks in
we
take our our pedal from off you know we
the our foot from off the pedal a little
bit because we're like i don't know if
it's working let's kind of go back so we
didn't even actually give the strategy
enough full-on effort full-on whatever
you re the new strategy i think is not
only going to work but it will work but
you got to give it enough time to work
so that's just something i've learned um
a couple weeks not enough time to judge
it i would judge it by
a couple months especially and to that
point todd just said it in the training
earlier don't judge a video by the
upload of day one even the first week
even a month or even a year not that you
have to go a whole year but you'll
really know if the new strategy works
after 12 months and you go shoot now
it's paying off and i've learned brandon
that
not just youtube but most things in life
that's how life works that a lot of
times
the
payoff
is not only is it not instantaneous it's
not even in a quarter or a month the
real payoff in life is a lot of small
steps don't done over time so anyways um
practically and tactically i would say
i think you're doing it exactly right i
think when you did quarantine costco
wholesale
wholesale halls strategic time those did
phenomenal yeah um you know which kind
of videos people want you to make just
keep making those videos and then i
would also say though final thing
is um do like a uh
even though you probably know this
keep this in mind
the creator who understands the viewer
best wins
i've been doing this over a decade
and the mindset i've adopted is i still
don't understand the viewer
so the mindset i want you to adopt is
assume you know nothing about your
audience even though you just talked to
them that's great and um
specifically i want you to go through
this
uh i think it's like a free worksheet it
might take an uh an opt-in i want you to
go through this digital marketer
customer avatar worksheet
and now it says get clear on who you're
selling to and you understand i mean
they're viewers and it's not that you're
selling but you may sell something but
the idea is you know who is your ideal
customer where are they hanging out what
are their challenges
this is going to give you
a lot of nuanced clarity
that um
is
going to help you
that'll help you make the viral videos
because you should make both yeah here's
what i mean you should make the costco
hauls you should make the coffee hacks
you should make the mom tips you should
make the evergreen content that's the
evergreen strategy that'll bring
sustainability to the youtube business
essentially
but especially with your faith and your
perspective your family values
maybe the things that get your wife
fired up the topics that your wife would
really want to talk about the polarizing
topics you guys have viral videos in you
if you have the courage to talk about
them and i just mean commentating or
talking about parenting or talking about
culture talking about which rely which
ties into motherhood yeah on the other
side of some content like that
it that could boost your subscribers 5
10 15 and and then the data because
think about it it's both in what you
understand is you talk about
she understands
who she's talking to
and i would argue
you know off the cuff you'd probably say
i think i know but you gotta really know
and video ideas will come out of doing
that customer avatar worksheet thing
that's good then when you make some of
those videos
boom now it's really going deep into
understanding demographics keywords
psychographics of the audience
and and that'll bring in new audience
and then they're like oh i just love
your wife like she's so cool like i vibe
with her like this is kind of cool on a
journey coffee cold brew you know costco
halls parenting and
and then people they meet you in a
moment from some of those viral videos
but they stay with you for the journey
for the value and the promise and the
problem you solve over time
and that's the kind of stuff we want to
do we had a bunch of i pulled down i
unlisted you can beat me for it i
unlisted a bunch of marriage videos
because they were our worst performing
videos okay um
and we're going to re-upload
those onto a channel that's just going
to be for our marriage and our faith
yeah that was our idea to re to niche
separately so we didn't confuse the
water here you have thoughts on that
yeah i mean i i think
the other tip is is is what we've talked
about today is also really studying
five to ten channels that you would want
to have their same success and it is it
is true if the avatar wants
um
you know freezer meal prep costco hauls
food stuff
then
being clear that they may not want
or or probably don't want marriage and
all of these other things
trimming that content out of your
channel is probably a really good
strategy okay cool i was i was hesitant
man
but i was just kept hearing your voice
going knees down niche down each down
that's also that's also a hard thing to
do so i want to commend you because a
lot of people are just unwilling to make
hard decisions
to steer their youtube channel towards
success and here's the thing it's your
choice it's your tube it's youtube um
but it is for us it's for our viewer
yeah and it also
and also for the practicality of of the
business side it's like if you want this
to build extra income or be a full-time
income or baseline income like i went
full-time a few months ago because of
some health stuff on youtube yeah
yeah because like you're forced into
full time and trying to
um i had a bunch of health stuff
autoimmune stuff
put me out of commission couldn't even
take care of my kids and it was either
stay in my church and be out every
couple months
or do something where i had flexibility
and build a future for my family what
i've got
got it so even more so i appreciate you
sharing that brandon is uh
is is being
business-minded and some people you know
i i don't sense it's not a negative
thing because ethical business is
solving problems for a profit ethical
business is helping people
solve problems adding value to their
life and it's an exchange you're adding
more value than you're taking especially
if the free video you're adding free
video
and you're taking five minutes of a
pre-roll or five seconds if they want to
skip the pre-roll ad and then of course
affiliate marketing other things you
could do
but um
you making hard decisions to say what is
the shortest path to revenue in this
season for you guys is smart as well
because the cool thing is once you also
build a baseline business and this is
kind of like you know my greatest
passion brandon
is um is
really
leadership
and business from a faith perspective
but i'm teaching youtube
um and i love youtube
and what
i'm about to turn 38 and my vision is
and i said this years ago that when i
went in my 40s i wanted to go hard on my
personal channel and i do not upload
there
and probably start a new podcast
and and probably go leadership business
and faith uh or leadership in business
from a faith perspective john maxwell
kind of as an inspiration but new school
on some of those ideas i hear you
quoting john he's on staff at our church
it's where in west palm beach what the
heck yeah i hear you quoting john all
the time he preaches two or three times
a year christ fellowship in west palm
beach can you get him to text me i mean
what's going on here no i'm just kidding
um uh and so
um
that's uh
that's kind of part of the vision but
here's one of the things that i'm also
doing in that process like part of think
media and part of what we're building is
almost like paul making tents
it's like i got a vision for the impact
i want to make the books i want to make
but i also uh have a grace for
entrepreneurship and i want to lay a
foundation and also the team we're
building and the multiple sectors of
society we want to impact so anyways um
it sometimes especially when we're
mission driven and purpose-driven
probably like you we are just sometimes
we hedge
from like really going all in on like
let's really monetize this thing but i
want people to hear in our community
like if you know you're coming from a
good place and you're really serving
people and solving a real problem
really
be business-minded really think about
how you can scale revenue what's the
shortest path to revenue figure out what
your financial target that you need is
and literally multiply it by five or ten
i need 5k a month to take four or 10k a
month turn that into 50 and start
thinking about how you're going to earn
50k a month because
it's money for the mission it's money
for growing the youtube channel hiring
an editor thinking bigger
uh and then
margin for the ups and downs see if
you're doing 50 a month obvious people
probably like it must be nice but
imagine if you're doing 50 a month and
smart and frugal and saving like joseph
setting aside grain then when everybody
else freaks out because there's a famine
for six months you're fine you're like
well i mean we had a couple good months
because we were smart we were
business-minded we weren't afraid of of
really
uh building wealth so that we could have
stability help financial health for my
family and for my business and maybe
that's easier said than obviously done
but ultimately
that kind of think with what you're
doing right now in terms of
strategizing your channel i think is is
what's next it sounds like you're making
a lot of the right moves uh do that
customer avatar sheet
um and then really think about
what is your
game plan and then just stay laser
focused on that and then i would say
like
you've been disciplined enough to pull
some of those videos off the channel
i want to encourage you to actually
not even do the creative outlet thing
man i know it's up to you because i mean
obviously you're going to do whatever
you want anyway no let's already
but you get if you if you you know greg
mcewen essentialism
is a book and if in worth checking out
uh gary keller the one thing another
good book daisy link him up uh
essentialism gary keller one thing
man with where you're at right now it's
just so important that you just say
where am i point a
and where is a b c d e not z that's like
the end of the journey where's e where
do i want to be in like five moves
and stop doing everything else that
doesn't have to do with getting there we
try that at home
a few months outside my wife is the face
right it's all her
um and i did i did more content with her
but if it's moms as our audience i can't
think like a mom man i've been trying
like i can't write for her as well as
she could write for herself and she's
running an ultrasound department at a
hospital she ain't got no time
what's that so what do you mean
so like i no matter how much time i put
into this i can't write content for her
i can't come up like i i make thumbnails
and they're too masculine they're not
you know what i mean they're not
clicking with her audience as well
um so we've got to make content that i
can write and i can shoot
which would be that marriage content on
another marriage content or doing some
other things something doing some
personal coaching with people things
like that and that's working
none of us making money except for this
but i can't do more of this right like i
can't shoot me for the mom channel you
see what i'm saying yeah but i don't
think i think
you mean you got to ultimately make your
own decisions but if you're trying to
start a new channel with the marriage
thing and get that whole thing going and
that's not making money
the thing that is
is what you want to add fuel to
period it's good to hear that man you
know what i mean like and and everybody
in the community needs to hear that too
it's sort of like okay
that's the bright spot that is the
it's it's it's a lot easier to get
five dollars a month from affiliate
marketing to 50 than it is to start a
new channel to even get to the five
if this channel is already making money
you are already
you've created so much momentum already
you have so much to build on already so
the mindset i would challenge
is you can figure it out
you can't like you're never gonna be all
time at thinking like a mom
but you can solve the problem
a i think you could think like a mom
immerse yourself in mom culture and mom
books and mom videos b
re-strategize how you're you know
supporting your your wife re-strategize
your schedule just meaning like so what
does it mean
to
design a couple thumbnails and then let
her judge and direct it and coach me
what does it mean to like figure out we
ask a family member to take the kids
saturday mornings so that we can do our
brainstorm because that one brainstorm
influences the content for the whole
week what is it like just what systems
do i need to put in place around
and to bring it all back to essentialism
if you're exactly where you're and
you're not even
at point a it's the new point a you've
you've traveled through the whole like
negative integers up until like you've
done a whole lot to get where you are
now so you go this is exactly where we
are and we're going to shut off
everything else for a time
and focus on how much you make in a
month will you share
oh sure man i don't mind uh adsense it
fluctuates between 80 and 120
affiliate stuff
wildly fluctuates probably
averages uh
like a hundred and
average is like 100 a month right now
like 200 bucks a month
a little over that yeah so like 250 a
month yep
so if we 10 extra 250 a month
uh that's
2500 a month would that be helpful for
your family
um
you know you talked about storing up the
grain and all that earlier we're only
okay right now because we dave ramsey
like crazy people for the last decade
yeah um and our plan is to white knuckle
it and a little bit of gary vaynerchuk
the you know the longer you hold the
breath that's what the person who holds
her breath the longest wins yeah uh we
want to put everything back in the
business hire somebody hire the editor
hire the social media manager we want to
grow a business man
so but 2500 would be better than
yeah because then i could hire somebody
yeah
so so this is this is what it would look
like in
coffee with kennel crew think crew
i would game plan this out this
essentially is at least my approach
brandon if i'm you with what i know and
you have to debrief with your wife of
course yeah yeah i would say
look at what we just know for sure
this is the channel with momentum this
is the channel that is earning 250.
here's our mission
10x revenue
what is it gonna take and by the way
there's outside of the box strategies
for that right like i mean it could be
she creates a digital product a meal
plan a checklist she creates something
you know
a lot of ways so you could think about
that but just how do we 10x revenue
because you just told me then that gets
us to point e which is now higher editor
systematize it more get it from 2500 to
10 grand a month so
uh
and the power of focus is you need to
make a list of what you're saying no to
now you could also consider like there
might be not a lot of value in social
media for you right now um that might be
a distraction the instagram link on the
page is broken i just noticed that
anyways uh as well so i just changed the
account name today that's why
okay cool yeah uh and so
uh and units go into
like rather than even worrying i know
you already made the marriage videos
who cares the time it takes to upload
them and thumbnail and title like no
it's the one thing
it is and and this is it's so hard to
start a youtube channel it's so hard to
start a business it's so hard to start a
family it's so hard to have anything the
power of focus is trying to is putting
all of your creative energy
all of your best creativity and
especially when you're dealing with
health challenges like a lot of us are
chronic pain different issues that we're
facing uh were in our family i'm dealing
with repetitive stress injury and carpal
tunnel my wife needs a surgery i just
share that because it's more important
your time is more limited your creative
time your energy time your peak energy
time you may only have a few hours a
week you can't dilute that between
multiple projects and especially when a
project is
is profitable and and let me just from
my vantage point encourage you with this
from what you guys have already pulled
off with thumbnails from your wife's
energy and the thumbnails and from
videos and what i've seen
from what you've already achieved with
almost 6 000 subscribers if you really
get focused
you really go deep on that customer
avatar sheet and you really just do the
work and keep you know the stuff you've
learned from watching our stuff and um
like
it's it's gonna scale
because you've already proven that you
can earn 250 dollars my friend you can
get to 2500 on the other side of focused
execution
both of us working full-time all the
time never having any time for this
you're also going to get there
probably no matter what but it might
take 10 years but you could get there in
four months
if you focus
and get and if you've done ramsay then
you already know what it is to have
gazelle intensity and to like
just just get crazy focused and put
gazelle intensity towards one thing
that's what i'm talking about you go all
in and you and you might be shocked and
by the way
it might not be four months it might be
six but it's not gonna be five years
because of diluting your focus between
too many things i'm going all in build
your wife's personal brand build up the
channel
focus on the nuances and just keep
tweaking the one thing and improving the
one thing and bro this is going to work
sean you give me a lot to chew on man i
really i really appreciate it um can i
plug you real quick
um dude you have been a humongous part
of every bit of success we success we
have because of your story because of
your lack of fear and sharing your faith
you are the man i appreciate it we love
what you did we worshiped with you live
when you guys did grow with video live
2021 um and we already bought our
tickets we'll be there in may
um and that's a big big thing for us we
couldn't do the vip thing i'm sorry this
uh but we're gonna be there and
everybody watching should be there too
because uh if you if you work it it
works
man brandon i really appreciate you
thank you for your kind words thanks for
being connected to our community i can't
wait to uh hug you in uh in may in las
vegas and bro
that's a fun target it's october right
november december
january february march april may
i have the audacity to say on the other
side of execution you're at 2500 bucks a
month from your youtube channel by then
or more
you are man off it's going to be a lot
of work it's going to be a lot of family
strategy and times you get it but like
you got 250. i know it just because it
was exactly what happened to me
um
niche is a little bit different tech is
very profitable that's the mom thing man
we do a product review no views yeah but
i mean i'm not saying it even has to
just be product reviews i'm just saying
um even with the halls and and
brand deals are a thing even with the
size you're at now but as you get your
views up a little bit as a micro
influencer i'm saying the whole business
model you just work the whole thing you
go this is the business model that's the
thing it's like what are we doing this
this business
wife personal brand to moms
like with the momentum you already have
work it man
and i mean if if we
uh get meet in the lobby and you're like
bro i'm only at
2186 bucks a month and i'm like i'm
sorry i apologize
but i'm telling you like it's i i i feel
it it's gonna work man but i know it's a
lot to execute it's a lot of hard work
ahead um
but that's it's it's not based on
nothing you've already executed this far
now it's time to just get really dialed
in and check out that customer avatar
worksheet that'll blow your mind you
guys should do that together you got it
sean thank you for your time man i value
it appreciate it thank you brandon
coffee with candle crew uh hit the like
button and uh
thank you for being here to uh today
super grateful for brandon
and uh i feel it man
there's something about the journey of
building on youtube
and uh
um
i just want to commend brandon and i
want to commend you watching the stuff
takes
work takes a lot of time you put in a
lot of work maybe going in one direction
and then you'll
pivot directions eventually and
sometimes it's emotional you've made
videos about other topics what do i do
with those and do i start multiple
channels and what do i what do i do
um but there's something about
having gazelle intensity just getting
focused on a vision even if the vision's
a little bit cloudy
just running for it and making
continuous adjustments on the path
making a commitment that you're not
gonna quit
make it a commitment that sometimes you
win sometimes you learn
john maxwell west palm beach for florida
um and
that you just keep going and keep
learning
you know
i feel like we've achieved a moderate
level of success at think media and some
people are like dude i just discovered
what you guys are doing congratulations
yesterday i was at a grocery store line
and the teller was like man he was like
wait you're a content creator because
somebody came up to me and was like is
that sean cannell even though i had a
mask on
and it was kind of weird and uh and he
was like oh you're a content creator
congrats on your your success you know
and he just heard of it like we just met
he goes how many subs do you have i go
1.8 million he's like oh my gosh
congrats
like overnight success in his eyes he
didn't know who i was now we met and i
was like yeah bro
but i've only been grinding painfully
for over a decade
and i heard a quote once that says
overnight success takes 10 years
there's that moment where there's that
breakthrough or that moment where all of
a sudden they're like wait a minute you
earn 2 500 bucks a month kind of like
passive income from creating youtube
content you earn 10 grand a month from
from creating youtube content you're
like yeah
yeah just uh
and and i was able to tell him too he
goes man how long have you been doing
that because that was what this guy
asked me yesterday his name was ray
i go
oh man i i really started about 2010
when i actually started for my church in
2007. but i started think media in 2010
and he goes uh i go yeah for about five
years i was just grinding on the
sidewalk i had a full-time job and
and then for the last six years it's
been crazy and it was kind of slow right
at first but now it's grown and
uh and he was like wow and and think
about
that conversation transpired in a matter
of minutes
but i was summarizing
over 10
years
of focused intensity
of
willing to get up when i got knocked
down
of
waking up out of bed and feeling pumped
to create content
and of a lot more moments waking up out
of bed and saying why am i even doing
this
and a lot of a lot more times of having
self-doubt and discouragement
and haters comments that get under your
skin
and family troubles and multiple
surgeries over the last 10 years that my
wife has had and a surgeon that made a
mistake that set her into four months of
hell because
he installed the gastric stimulator
wrong and it was rubbing against her in
rib cage and started throwing all this
medication at her about four years ago
and seasons of life where now we're
trying to raise a kid and seasons of
life where it's a blessing to have a
team but
people got problems you got problems
your spouse's problems your sister is
weird and i don't she is hard to be
around i'm just kidding like i don't
know your sister you know your cousin
larry is sketchy and and people got
problems dude it's been it's been 10
years of problems but it's also been a
blessing
because of having a clear vision and
actually seeing that this thing is real
man i love hearing brandon's story
because that's the real grind 250 bucks
a month
so not a lot of people would have
persevered as long as he has
to
not get i could just go get a job and
make more more than that see when i was
waiting tables
at red robin
bottomless fries
royal burger with the egg on it
mud pie
come on california burger california
chicken i might say an ensenada chicken
platter
can i get you another strawberry
lemonade refill with that
when i was working at red robin
i made more money on a friday night and
a saturday weekend double shift in tips
than i made on youtube in six months for
doing 600 times the work
and that my friend is why most people
will not actually seize this opportunity
called youtube
because
the perseverance required through the
vow the valley of starting something up
and pivoting along the way
and getting the education
and and the tilt.com did a study that
revealed that the average contra uh
content entrepreneur the average youtube
entrepreneur invests ten thousand
dollars in themselves
to get their content entrepreneurship
business going
most people will not do that
because the sunk cost
appearance on the front end
it's not even appearance it's the sunk
cost reality on the front end all you're
doing is time that seems to be going
nowhere money that seems to be going
nowhere growth that seems to be going so
slow frustration that seems to be going
slow potentially not getting support
having unsupported family members or
people around you and probably the worst
of all and most unsupportive person that
you're sometimes having to have
conversations with is the conversation
in your own head
and in your own head your own thoughts
of self-doubt and your own
self-criticism and your own thoughts of
putting out a video and then looking at
those analytics and then tearing
yourself down you need to stop doing
that
but these are the kind of battles you
have to fight through
in order to actually break through
and start building momentum on youtube
and when you actually get there
financially
it also is still not that substantial
because i remember in 2015 when i went
full time
and i was making 300 400 bucks a month
in october of 2015
and it was a few months of perseverance
before it even turned into something
more see logical wisdom
would have been
at that exact moment instead of going
all in on my youtube channel would have
been to go get a job a job
it would have been to go get a job
because that would have been a promised
amount of money in that moment
but this
is the power
of vision
vision is one of your most valuable
assets what is your vision for what's
possible what is your vision
for your youtube channel what is your
vision for where you want to be with
your family what is your why that you're
fighting for reasons come first results
come second
see
when i would when everybody at red robin
would go out and party
uh of my co-workers and then i would
either get rest or go work on a video
it was because i had a vision that even
though i wasn't getting to celebrate and
enjoy life in that moment
i was
investing in my future by making hard
decisions that did not appear to be
paying off in that moment it's like our
friend dave ramsey says that's why we
live today like no one else so that
later in life we can live like no one
else
and if you put your head down for five
to ten years and i don't mean
dabble on youtube and just watch a ton
of youtube videos and just say you're a
creator but you never create anything i
mean put your head down and get to
freaking work if you put your head down
as malcolm gladwell would say with the
ten thousand hour rule and you're not
just practicing but it's deliberate
practice it's structured it's
intentional it's like carrie knew off
would say that it's your practice in
your green zone it's your you working on
your craft in your green zone in his
book uh
at our best at your best in your green
zone when you when you put in that kind
of work for five to ten years then
you run into somebody at whole foods and
bought five hundred dollars of groceries
i'm not trying to flex that's just how
much it cost because it was also whole
foods aka whole paycheck uh and and
and they go oh my gosh you're a youtube
you know successful youtuber 1.8 and and
you're like yeah i am
and and it is amazing and the accolades
are amazing but bro if you understood
the grind if you understood the dark
night of the soul if you understood the
hustle that it took to build this
like that's just something that most
aren't willing to pay
but i want to encourage you
it's the law of sacrifice
you got to give up to go up
and i want to encourage you what are you
and ask you what are you willing to
sacrifice for your dreams
what are you willing to invest for your
dreams the time the hustle the blood the
sweat the tears
the lack of support
the law of sacrifice
what do you what price are you willing
to pay
for what you want to build and for your
vision for your family for your future
for your goals
for how you want to be remembered for
your legacy
for the business you want to build
for the
well you want to dig dig your well
before you're thirsty for the digital
real estate you want to claim get the
real estate now because youtube's not
going anywhere but it's going to be
harder five years from now it's gonna be
more competition
i should have bought a house you know
five years ago you and me both
i should have bought bitcoin eight
months ago you and me both bro i did too
i wish i bought more
like i should have i would have i could
have no you can't go back but you can go
forward what price are you willing to
pay
for your dreams
investing in your channel investing in
your future
if you're just joining
me for this rant at this moment
this might sound like just oh oh
hype oh cool you know it sounds
inspirational motivational bro what
about the tactics
rewind or watch the replay which will be
up here on the think media podcast
channel the first hour where we talked
about six surprising insights from a
youtube employee that just revealed that
the youtube algorithm is not against you
that if you master the platform you
master your message
you master understanding who you're
talking to and you learned the
challenging skill set of creating
quality content like youtube is open
season friends this next decade is going
to be the best decade on youtube i hope
you smash that like button if you're
fired up for the future i hope you're uh
ready to uh
get your grind on get your mind right
and get your hustle
uh focused and uh i want you to know
that i appreciate you i'm rooting for
you and i respect you for even being
here i'm also grateful that you'd even
be here and be a part of this
show marcus i appreciate you and listen
um ivan brandon uh thank you for being
here on the back end i know we had the
powell family but uh we did some q a we
had some guests on
i look forward to having you on a future
episode of coffee with canal let me know
your biggest aha moment from today but
more than that it's i i'm not here
actually legit to inspire you i hope
maybe you're inspired i don't want you
to just be like oh cool my brain was
tickled i have kind of a cool new idea i
hope so but let me ask you this question
what are you gonna take action on
what are you gonna go do
what are you gonna put into practice
what is your next
thing on your calendar where you're
either creating content or doing market
research or filling out that customer
avatar sheet or reading the at your best
book to get your productivity and your
schedule right if you want to take
advantage of any of the show notes
definitely check out the youtube
description where we have a lot of
things that we talked about down there
and uh
we will get you rocking and rolling uh
daisy will tell you how to get on the
show someday we drop a link in the
comments a lot of times you drop a link
in our inner circle program or video
racket academy try to get to as many
people as possible i'm excited because
coffee with kennel i do believe is back
every other week we have the youtube
made simple show that is uh uh more
um
every other week as well and uh
i'm in las vegas but we did build up a
think media office up a home office up
in seattle and i do have a clock mounted
on my desk and um
i don't know it's like a little u-rig
arm clamp u-rig arm clap is how i did it
the question the final question of the
day is a super chat
chat it's something like this my friend
it's probably this exact one small rig
so
what i did was i
i have the elgato
key light
um
the elgato key light arm that connects
to the back of a standing desk
or any desk
and um
oh you can't really see it as much here
so it's on the it'll be better on the
home office i'll show you what we're
looking at here if you haven't seen this
is a fun video
uh play here we go so there's the
there's the clock
so if you look behind
the speaker there's a there's the elgato
key light and it just has a black pole
that's connected to the back of the desk
connected to the side of that
is
this clamp
and that clamp connects with the little
jaws right there
and then that
eighth inch screw
goes into the side of the clock the
clock has tripod mounts on it
i think the clock is linked up in the
description but it's actually a workout
clock
and i that helps me stay on time for
live streams
i actually started that clock right off
uh to the side of me here
during this live stream and i maxed it
out it's at 999 minutes because we're at
we're way beyond that's it's only goes
for like an hour and a half which is how
long my live streams probably should be
let me know if you like it when we're
hanging out for 2 hours and 19 minutes
today
i definitely got to get some stuff done
before i'm on daddy duties and before i
watch my son while my wife
does some errands i really appreciate
you i know a lot of questions are coming
in so i look back i look forward to
seeing you for a think media podcast in
the future smash like if you haven't
smashed like share especially the first
part of this video if you haven't shared
that and if you want to check out
something next uh check out the think
media podcast click or tap the screen
you can um you know watch one of the
episodes from that and there's a lot of
deep strategic youtube videos that are
gonna help you grow faster i appreciate
you my name is sean cannell this has
been coffee with cannell and i cannot
wait to see you in the next episode
until then keep crushing it keep
smashing it and we will talk soon